الى هذه الصور المباشره والتي همم ننقلها
لكم من العاصمه الاسبانيه مدريد مدريد هذه
الاحتجاجات احتجاجات طبعا في همم الشوارع
على تردد بسبب طبعا تردي المستوى المعيشي
في همم البلاد واا طبعا همم كل هذه
الاحداث تاتي بعد تطورات الازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه التطورات التي القت بطلالها
على الاقتصاد العالمي اقتصاد اوروبا بشكل
خاص من ضمنها اسبانيا عشرات الالاف الان
يتظاهرون همم في العاصمه مدريد احتجاجا
على تردد المعيشه خصوصا فيما يتعلق
بالقطاع همم الصحي ونحن همم نرى عشرات
الالاف في شوارع العاصمه الاسبانيه مدريد
الشوارع التي اغلقت بسبب هذه
التظاهرات هناك بعض المصادر تشير الى ان
الاعداد قد تجاوزت 200,000 محتج خرجوا الى
شوارع العاصمه الاسبانيه احتجاجا على تردد
المستوى المعيشي في البلاد ما يشهده
العالم ايضا من ارتفاع نسب التضخم من
ارتفاع ايضا
التكاليف الطاقه ايضا كذلك عليهم كل هذه
تاتي طبعا مشاهدينا بعد تفاقم الازمه
الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وبعد ان وصلت معها الدول
الاوروبيه الى همم طبعا اوضاع الى اوضاع
اقتصاديه باصعب ربما قد تكون باوضاع غير
مسبوقه في التاريخ الحديث للقاره العجوز